all true in the world yet at least we
were doing good to see you back in one
piece
hey the captain
I'm impressed you smell we do the heist
and get off this rock we've got a crew
to rival the legends time to make some
money don't you agree
now we're ready quite the motley she's
right
you need to disguise to get anywhere
near Bozek fortunately my pleasure meet
me up it's a wonderful Bocek keeps the
key around his neck get your disguise oh
I removed this diva let me know it
I taught I was sitting here Milou we
should head to st. sport
well oh yes try these on
[Music]
I don't believe you had your hands on my
property
my lowly my dear friend head man Bozek
is sleeping off the attentions of these
two love
you'll answer for that wrong and it's
against the law
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
here you are our web the shipping logs
that show Bo sex defiance of the Kings
decrees come on it's time to go
on your feet man your stations prepare
to sail
finally home to bet Nick I've missed my
clan before we leave for bet Nick talked
to the crew then we leave
you
when my crew turned traitor I never
thought I'd head into town and get a
drink
careful here these orcs aren't yet part
of the Covenant